la cámara de representantes de mayoría
republicana aprobó el proyecto para
levantar el techo de la deuda con 314
votos a favor y 117 en contra fueron los
moderados demócratas y republicanos los
que impulsaron esta iniciativa que ahora
pasa al senado donde ya analistas
legislativos aquí en el Capitolio dicen
que se va virtualmente a probarlo más
pronto posible dado que la mayoría de El
senado es demócrata de hecho ya se está
considerando el viernes en la noche como
fecha límite para la votación de El
senado y para que este proyecto pase a
la mesa de el presidente biden Para que
se firme como ley y se eviten de Fox
financiero de hecho al respecto el
presidente ya reaccionó diciendo que
instaba precisamente al senado a firmar
y aprobar cuanto antes este proyecto de
ley aprobado en la cámara de
representantes y que era un paso
trascendental para evitar este defod
financiero y seguir adelante seguir
avanzando en el rumbo económico del país
analistas políticos también ven como una
gran Victoria para el presidente biden
está aprobación esta mediación y este
cabildeo que hizo para que la cámara de
representantes que es de mayoría
republicana haya votado un proyecto que
se negoció entre republicanos y
demócratas entre legislativo y El
Ejecutivo Y estos seguramente será un
argumento de campaña de Cara a su misión
de reelección en el 2024